action commise sur place on choqué le
monde entier bout de chat et c346 villes
brutalement tués ce vendredi
Ursula wanderleyen et Joseph Borel sont
sur place vous le voyez sur ces images
la présidente de la Commission
européenne et le chef de la diplomatie
européenne doivent par la suite
rencontrer le président wolo
diverselinski un déplacement pour
réaffirmer le soutien de l'Union
européenne à l'Ukraine on va tout de
suite écouter un extrait de la prise de
parole d'Ursula mandalayen
c'est l'impensable qui s'est produit ici
nous avons vu le visage cruel de l'armée
de Poutine
nous avons vu l'insouciance et la
froideur avec lesquels ils ont occupé la
ville c'était
ici à bout de chat nous avons vu
l'humanité se briser le monde entier
étant deuil avec les habitants de Bucha
et ce sont eux qui défendent la
frontière de l'Europe qui défendent
l'humanité
qui défend de la démocratie
et c'est pourquoi nous sommes solidaires
avec eux dans cette importance